[Music]
defects in retinal genes caused a
devastating form of childhood blindness
gene therapy is really I think at the
forefront of treating retinal
degenerations there are now over 20
clinical trials addressing various
diseases in ways that we didn't really
think possible before having to make a
decision on his behalf has been a real
struggle this treatment could change our
lives this could stop a truly terrible
disease as we tackle the problem of
childhood blindness this is going to be
a real breakthrough and our ability to
change the course of the disease in a
way we never thought possible
[Music]
maverick is my firstborn child he has
been the most amazing a child to raise
from the day that he was born I didn't
have a lot of experience with babies
before I had him but I just noticed that
he had a blank stare checked his
tracking vision and it was non-existent
we went through all the genetic testing
and it came back positive for Leber's
congenital amaurosis with a specific
genetic marker of rpe65
the cones and the rods in the eyes don't
allow for light perception so he is
legally blind with specifically
low-light blindness he also doesn't have
peripheral vision or a vision below his
waist
it's almost tunnel vision
[Music]
up here is my room and these are my
placement this is my high patch it has
to be the right lighting for him to see
once the Sun Goes Down his world is very
dark we take him inside turn on all the
lights until it's time for bed Mavericks
condition is degenerative
there is no time frame of when the
degeneration will take place but it is a
well-known fact that he will be
completely blind in later years took his
thoughts quite some time to subside into
sense of fire and sulfur a torched
landscape in December of 2017 the FDA
approved gene therapy for maverick
specific condition and so we went and
talked to doctor Niguel shortly after it
was approved maverick was 6 years old
when I first met him and this family for
a long time had struggled with getting a
diagnosis and then we're very excited
finally to hear that there was a
treatment lux Jonah is a gene
replacement therapy whereby were
delivering a normal healthy copy of the
rpe65 gene to patients who have two
defective copies this medication is a
virus which has essentially been
modified so it's only job is to deliver
the genetic material we deliver this
virus with a very fine needle underneath
the retina and then we have a healthy
copy of a gene that's been missing and
the cells that normally make it
unfortunately with this disease the
cells that absorb the light the
photoreceptors are constantly
degenerative and there gets to be a
point where there simply aren't enough
cells to function even if we were to
deliver that gene back
so it makes a lot of sense to treat
earlier pediatric patients young
patients when they have those cells
there and just need a normal copy of the
gene to make the protein and thus
function again so treatment early in
children is really the way to go to
achieve the best results here at
Children's Hospital Los Angeles we've
treated 17 patients so thirty four eyes
we have data that the treatment effect
is stable without any loss in function
five years ago there were no treatments
for this disease and for the bulk of
retinal degenerations these patients if
they were lucky got a diagnosis with
genetic testing but beyond that there
wasn't much that we could do aside from
get the most out of the vision that they
have since the FDA approval of lux
aeterna that's really opened the door to
not just treating this relatively rare
retinal degeneration but essentially any
retinal degeneration this has been
probably the most difficult decision
that I've ever had to make in my entire
life it makes me very nervous because it
is so new if it doesn't go well it's my
fault because I chose to do this to my
child I honestly feel like I hit the
jackpot when I had maverick I don't know
any other seven-year-old kid that could
handle everything that he has been
through with such appreciation for life
you know he is willing to do or try
anything after today our life could
potentially change forever
[Music]
love you he might go back home and for
the first time have fun with his friends
by the pool as it's getting dark ride
his bike at dusk go trick-or-treating
these are the sort of improvements that
really change a child's life and the
motor confidence that comes with
ambulating and interacting with the
environment in a way that they couldn't
before I think really has lifelong
consequences
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it takes seven days for the corrected
DNA to be absorbed so at seven days he
could potentially see again it just
comes in very small doses and it could
take up to four months they said
[Music]
maverick had his two surgeries and we
are home the first day that I really
noticed that something was different was
riding in a car and he said mom I'm just
looking outside and I'm seeing what is
outside the windows like I've never been
able to see through the windows seems so
small but it was really life-changing
for him to be able to look out of a
window ready okay listen to me
one more game of tag maverick sit ready
one more game the past seven years we
don't even come in the backyard at night
this is us it's a true miracle well come
here get him he has a whole new level of
Independence and he is ready to conquer
anything that is given to him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you